este santuario de vida salvaje en el
norte de namibia abarca más de 800
hectáreas
aquí vive una docena de grandes felinos
rescatados
[Música]
cuando lea peterson entra al recinto
todos los guepardos saben que es hora de
comer pero primero deben ganarse lo que
es importante que se mantengan en forma
a pesar de vivir en cautiverio
[Música]
aquí
shauis up sexy
los veterinarios y trabajadores del
centro tratan de darle a estos felinos
una alta calidad de vida muy distinta de
las vidas que alguna vez tuvieron show
sabana ancha sabana y sacha eran
mascotas había cinco personas en la casa
rainbow fue encontrada a un lado de la
carretera amarilla también la tenía un
granjero en una casa la trajimos el año
pasado así que todas vienen de
situaciones de circunstancias diferentes
durante los últimos 100 años la
población mundial de pardos se ha
desplomado pasando de 100.000 a unos
7000 y sigue en caída su hábitat natural
también se ha reducido drásticamente se
encuentran en la lista roja de especies
amenazadas y están clasificados como
vulnerables aunque algunos científicos
están pidiendo que vuelvan a
considerarse en elda pero son un
problema para los granjeros que no
quieren convivir con ellos por eso a
veces les disparan tenemos que encontrar
una manera de vivir con los animales
salvajes
wildlife
para evitar confrontaciones entre los
guepardos y los granjeros o el santuario
inventó una solución innovadora
estos perros pastores de anatolia son
entrenados para proteger a los rebaños
de cabras y ovejas de los ataques de
guepardos
lo que hacemos es poner a los cachorros
aquí con el rebaño cuando cumplen cuatro
meses así crean un vínculo con las
cabras los guepardos le tienen miedo a
los perros y los evitan en la medida de
lo posible una vez que han alcanzado la
edad adulta los perros son vendidos a
los granjeros locales el centro ya ha
vendido 600 a distintos granjeros en
todo el país uno de ellos vive aquí
cuidando este rebaño de cabras aunque
los granjeros le temen a los guepardos
la onu afirma que el daño que le hacen
al ganado es leve pero si los granjeros
continúan matando una especie que ya se
encuentra en estado vulnerable podrían
acelerar
el perro me ayuda a detectar a los
depredadores en la sabana detectando su
olor y ahuyentando los gracias al perro
ya no tengo que matar guepardos
el santuario espera reconciliar el
entorno humano con el entorno natural y
transmitir el mensaje en las escuelas es
una parte importante de esta iniciativa
antes los humanos solían dispararle a
los guepardos al verlos porque notaban
que perdían ganado estos estudiantes han
viajado cientos de kilómetros para
aprender más sobre los guepardos y para
no considerarlos una amenaza de jesualdo
wey esta es una de las maneras en las
que podemos proteger a los ocupados y
evitar que se extingan están haciendo un
gran trabajo la mayoría de los guepardos
del centro son liberados de vuelta en su
hábitat natural después de haber sido
rehabilitados pero los más débiles
permanecerán en cautiverio por el resto
de sus vidas desde 1991 este santuario
ha salvado alrededor de 300 de pardos un
impulso muy importante para una especie
que necesita toda la ayuda posible